[Music]
meagan Markel may have retired from
acting but she could still land an Emmy
nom the newly minted Dutchess of Sussex
is on the Emmy nominating ballot for
Outstanding Supporting Actress in a
Drama Series for her role as Rachel Zane
in suits I'm going to make sure that he
gets the fair trial that he never had
now this is just the round of voting to
see who winds up on the final ballot
it's worth noting suits has never earned
any nominations in the past now Markel's
name could show up twice on the final
any ballot
parisa Fitz Henley is in contention for
a nomination for playing the Duchess in
lifetimes Harry and Meghan a royal
romance yeah I'm kind of a well-known
actress after all what is it you do
I'm kind of the Prince of England yeah
how's that going for you
meanwhile the real Markel has officially
cemented her place in the key royal
charity the 36 year old is now the
fourth patron of the royal foundation an
organization that was originally set up
to look after the charitable interests
of William and Harry then Kate Middleton
now the group has been renamed the Royal
Foundation of the Duke and Duchess of
Cambridge and the duke and duchess of
sussex soon after her engagement in
November Kensington Palace announced
that Markel would join the foundation
following her May 19th wedding and even
before then
Megan began immersing herself in the
causes she plans to champion taking part
in the first public forum of the
foundation in February alongside her
brother and sister-in-law and her then
fiance
[Music]
[Applause]